hi my name is my cherry ramakrishnan I'm
here with BuzzFeed and I'm here to play
with puppies and also answer your
questions
spoiler alert lots of spoilers are
coming for never have I ever season four
so if you don't want that
go that's what that was maybe you like
spoilers and you're into that then you
can stay I'm not ready
hey
oh my God oh my God you're all so
different and unique it's special nice
to meet you okay hi hi okay okay okay
okay okay okay all right there's a new
puppy smell oh my God oh my God yours
look cute yes you can give me all the
kisses hey chill that's my armpit okay
I'll close them personal
[Music]
thank you
I don't care I'm team you and you and
you oh my God you can you can buy my
finger oh my God you can do that I don't
care what are you doing don't don't get
too close to the lake I don't know if
that's it might hurt me don't do that be
careful I've always been team Davey
since the start for sure
too I think or it just makes quickly
there you go
foreign
just because like I love their Dynamic
but I was also like saying goodbye to
the show too right Davey's so grateful
for her mom and she's so grateful for
honesty everything in her life and I
could feel that as like an actor and
just just also my tree being on this
crazy crazy Journey you you're a ball
hog
you're being a blah blah
wow that's attitude
I have a ring why do we have rings I
don't know
um the last scene behind me who's
sneaking up behind me hey watching you
don't do anything dumb make good choices
the last thing we filmed was actually uh
Davey Eleanor and fad saying like what's
gonna happen when we go to university or
college and like saying about how
they're so scared and when Fab says Hey
TV you're like one of the bravest people
we know and we wouldn't be who we are
without you and then it was really sad
and then like Ramona cried and then I
was sad and then it was all very sad
not during that I cried when I rapped I
did cry a lot when I run
foreign
I totally thought he was cheating on her
oh my God thank God I don't want to see
ready are you ready to catch it you're
not ready I can I can see it okay move
on that's fine
[Music]
I have not seen love Victor before he
joined it was such a pleasure work with
him it was actually very fast and
furious because you know he's very
booked and busy hey hey come on let's be
okay he was a pleasure to work with it
was a pleasure I sorry I am so useless
In This Moment
[Music]
oh that's a good question
um I know it's okay you like the toys no
I I respect you for that you like my
hair I don't respect you for that Mindy
working with her is a delight and she is
amazing and I could not ask for a better
boss but truly I would love to work with
her where we could see each other as
equals and I could get to her level
because she's at a very high level but
you got me because we're on each other's
level right now oh my God
[Music]
honestly I don't know I don't know if it
makes sense because Davey's going to
Princeton so I don't know if it would
make sense in that way but first hey
what is okay it's okay it's seamless I
get scared of those two in photo shoots
it's fine all right don't worry you're
great okay now you're testing the waters
I can't help you and Mindy wanted me to
I mean hey I'd do anything for Mindy but
she wanted me to way to go Joe X be
grand
[Music]
I want to make sure that if I had to
face time right now and I would FaceTime
them right now I want to say Megan Megan
would FaceTime me and if she couldn't
FaceTime me she'd text me medley like
hey I'm busy and she has a puppy that
she's raising right now and is a proud
puppy mom and constantly tells me about
how tough it is I mean I have a doggo so
I remember these beautiful yet monstrous
days okay
[Music]
um yes you know why because I cannot lie
in your guys's company I lied about
lying and they still said that I said
the truth I just wanted to know if I
would be able to get away with the lie
and lie about flying
oh
[Music]
um I was kind of shook when Megan these
Italian was watching our show she like
posted it on her story Miss Megan D
stallion okay hey hey hey break it up
oh my God you guys listening okay good
job
yeah I took the whole harp it's kind of
big it's in the basement in the event I
get to properly take a job uh heart
lessons I would be able to actually
learn on little Davies hop
I would miss definitely
um oh my God you went in so fast and
furious you know what maybe you're just
a pro athlete I'm holding you back go
you're not a problem I don't know what
I'll miss about Davey anymore I'm sorry
[Music]
probably while we were filming episode
eight that's when we all got the script
so we found out like when everyone else
did and I remember him being very hyped
dealing with his hype is sometimes like
dealing with the young puppies energy
doing over there
you love my hair I get it you know what
no your rights revoked
I think it's honestly kind of great that
they ended up that way platonic
friendships are just as important right
and I like that never have I ever shows
that importance
I mean I've been auditioning for a lot
of stuff where I can during filming
because filming took a lot of time and a
lot of my schedule but I did audition
for um snakes and songbirds uh Hunger
Games pretty cool honestly I'm so
excited for that movie I'm not at all
salty about it because I just think it's
awesome that the movie is gonna happen
because I'm a big fan of the prequel and
it's gonna be great and it's even darker
than the original trilogy don't step on
his ear don't step on his ear
[Music]
I would play Trent Harrison because
Trent is cool oh okay that's a light
that's not a toy my guy okay
no
let's put your buttocks over here
I love you do you need affirmations you
want validation what is going on what is
going on oh my God yeah
um my Premiere look this season I
actually felt like a princess and I
usually get very anxious about red
carpet photos because sometimes I think
I look pretty ugly in all honesty but
this time I was quite happy with how I
looked and I felt actually beautiful
beef is quite cool I love Ali Wong she's
someone I'd love to work with she's a
Cool Woman In Comedy we love women in
comedy right guys because women are very
funny
[Music]
oh I know
um I mean there's been so many amazing
fans hey hey guys what did I just say
about fighting we're not doing that look
yeah I guess we're wins there's a lot
cooler fan gifts um but one fan
crocheted a whole unicorn like plushie
and if I gave that to you guys you guys
would rip that unicorn flashita I'm
looking at you smudge I like that
anyways this has been really fun I can't
remember what show I'm here for can't
remember anything because nothing
matters
bless you I am here apparently for never
have I ever uh season four do you want
me to be for you I'll fight with you all
these puppies are adoptable thanks to
rescue City so hey
come on watch season four
thank you